[Música]
y empezamos nuestra sección de economía
aquí en directo américa hablando con
nuestro periodista jorge hurtado jorge
buenas noches bienvenidos que tal mar
clara todo muy bien gracias y comencemos
hablando de como las históricas tasas de
interés en eeuu están afectando américa
latina' esta semana la reserva federal
de ese país subió en medio punto
porcentual su tasa de interés de
referencia el corto plazo y el aumento
es el más agresivo desde el año 2000
luego de dos años de pandemia y con las
tasas bajas a nivel global las personas
y los inversores y los países inclusive
que contrajeron deudas impulsaron la
economía comprando invirtiendo con
dólares más baratos pero ahora ese
panorama está cambiando por completo con
una inflación de la cual nadie se salva
la herramienta más efectiva para las
autoridades monetarias es subir los
tipos de interés buscando contener la
inflación pero asumiendo el riesgo de
reducir el crecimiento económico es la
primera vez en 22 años que el banco
central de eeuu sube tanto las tasas y
no será la última varios analistas
prevén que nuevas subidas serán
necesarias hasta situar los tipos de
interés entre el 1 75% y el 2% para
finales de julio de este año este
aumento de los tipos comenzó el año
pasado en varios países de américa
latina después seguido en eeuu el reino
unidos asia y próximamente lo haría el
banco central europeo según algunos
expertos para entender cómo este aumento
de tasas afectará a américa latina y la
economía de eeuu conversamos antes con
gustavo neffa él es economista socio
director de research for traders
el pasado solamente hubo un proceso de
suba de tasas que se asemejan que vamos
a estar experimentando de acuerdo a los
futuros porque hay una senda o una
tendencia de tasa de interés que des
cuenta de mercados futuros de esta tasa
tan relevante para la economía
norteamericana pero también para la
economía mundial y la tasa de corto
plazo la tasa de fans de la realidad
federal y la repercusión para estos 1 y
2 va a ser una política más agresiva con
un impacto en la desaceleración del
ritmo del crecimiento económico en los
próximos 6 a 9 meses y posiblemente
estemos viendo también un impacto muy
grande a través de los mercados con la
baja en el precio de los bonos en un
esquema renta fija las ventas se
implican baja precio de los bonos que
afectó sensiblemente a todos aquellos
emisores con menor calificación que
letizia como lo es latinoamérica en
general y a su vez en las emisiones más
largas aquella que tiene más
sensibilidad frente a los cambios en la
tasa interés jorge y los analistas
también esperan una salida de capitales
o una menor inversión en la región no es
así con las tasas de interés al alza en
américa latina donde aún se resienten
los efectos de la pandemia como por
ejemplo la pérdida de empleos y el lento
crecimiento la subida de las tasas
podría repercutir en que los impresores
muevan sus capitales de un país a otro
los mercados bursátiles también se
agitan y los bancos centrales toman como
referencia las decisiones de la mayor
economía del mundo asimismo los
inversores se refugian en el dólar
depreciando el resto de monedas esto por
supuesto disminuye el poder adquisitivo
de las personas el escenario
internacional también podría llevar a
las economías hacia un camino peligroso
advierte nuestro invitado escuchemos
pero siento de la economía
norteamericana se venía desacelerando
después del rebote fuerte del 2021 y las
últimas estimaciones banco mundial y del
world economic outlook del fbi han dado
cuenta de una desaceleración a la zona
del 33 y medio por ciento y consiguiente
al 2,3 por ciento en 2022 por lo cual
estamos yendo directo a una zona
peligrosa en la cual por un trimestre
quizás pueda tener o algunos meses puede
tener eeuu una pequeña recesión esto lo
que está descontando el mercado pero
recién para fines del 2023 el secreto no
es inmediato está suelta sin tener que
recién empieza y por lo pronto los
gastos los consumidores las presiones
viviendas la
dinámica del mercado laboral ha sido más
que satisfactoria pero los mercados
miran para delante entonces estamos
esperando las primeras reacciones de un
contexto global muy complicado a nivel
geopolítico o la guerra en ucrania por
esa desaceleración de china
que impone por estos casos de kobe que
complican toda la cadena de interacción
entre las empresas y proveedores y
fabricantes y por último de mente la
desalación de la economía norteamericana
que viene desde rebote como comentaba
anteriormente
jorge gracias por la información
económica y nosotros seguimos con más
aquí en france 24
[Música]